it's time to babble the [ __ ] on live
from the Jon Lovitz podcast theatre it's
Hollywood babble-on
with your hosts Kevin Smith and Ralph
Garman
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] I'm Kevin Smith it's Friday night
just a little reminder right you're
right it is Friday night I was just
about ready to foam the show with you
it's all right now I have to change days
it's Friday night in Hollywood
so let's battle the [ __ ] out I'm Kevin
Smith it's Friday Friday love when it's
Friday so I get to do that get to do it
yeah telling your name I'm Ralph Garman
hey everybody welcome to Hollywood
babble-on we're back on track thanks so
much for coming out tonight we
appreciate it
big big big news first things first
we're doing our first East Coast Babylon
I'm pregnant oh my god that's yours I
was like how weird I know I'm just
excited because we're going to
Philadelphia we just we just closed that
deal that's right we are on October 17th
Hollywood babble-on does its first East
Coast gig nobody in this room gives a
[ __ ] now but we're listening oh my god
we're going to Philly we're World Cafe
live I believe it is yes I'm not sure
when tickets go on sale they may be on
sale as soon as Monday but that's a cool
thing because it's in Philly which is
Ralph's hometown yes I'm very excited
yes so he could do it in front of his
people return like Christ to Jerusalem
riding an ass across to I'm sure when
it's all over now into the Liberty Bell
thanks so much for coming out tonight as
always we'd like to start the show with
shout outs people come particularly long
distances or celebrate special occasions
by coming to the show we like to reward
them with a little shout out then I
believe there is a song that goes along
with that
it's a shout out Kevin Brown so get your
[ __ ]
you gotta stop that that song just
brings out the best in me or the worst
no when I say the best I mean the gay it
just makes me miss being gay
why is your [ __ ] always limp when it
comes out what because I don't know I
think of Mike you come as Ella yeah yeah
I think it would be dirty if I'm like
get your [ __ ] out it's an erection God
is fine that's wrong can't hurt anybody
an erection screams like we're on [ __ ]
yeah threatening a limp [ __ ] is friendly
it's like and then you add in the cigar
smell at the end yeah good for anybody
I've been asking my wife to do that for
years I was like weren't my [ __ ] like a
cigar sniff it and like good but she
won't do or a cigarillo in your case
work that like a [ __ ] girl on road I
was handed this shadow just before we
came out on stage Ross Rogers Ross are
you in the house tonight where are you
we make some noise Ross it's a podcast
for [ __ ] sake man I just raise your
hand I've heard it we're not taking a
vote this isn't a quorum make some noise
Ross turns 18 years old today and he
came to celebrate his birthday bit of a
shot of whiskey on me he's 18 for [ __ ]
sake did you attend with Jennifer whoo
well that tells the story there doesn't
it we're gonna be some context Ross did
you get it for your lady Jennifer came
the life [ __ ] no I'm his babysitter
no what is the Jennifer relation she's
your aunt right on man well we're gonna
talk about [ __ ] all night
so that should be very awkward for you
Ross happy birthday if you don't
understand ask your aunt she'll explain
though how dare you sir she looks like a
very virginal young woman I'm not saying
she's done it but she knows about it we
all know about it welcome welcome
eighteen isn't this like a [ __ ] 21
and over now this is 18 this is it
really yeah
you can't drink here but you can you can
laugh here why would you laugh without
the Buddha night no certainly no reason
onstage
well welcome Matt welcome young men
today you are a man what is this day
different than all other days right
rabbi thank you by the end of the night
he'll be a man that's for sure Oh God
Jennifer you'll be a woman too
it's all gonna happen tonight it's gonna
be magical our Brian and Nicola here
from from the UK from England Brian a
Nicola right up front wait he goes our
Brian Nicola here no answer from the UK
clap clap clap do you think there's
another [ __ ] Nicola in this room
anywhere oh they must mean us except for
the UK it's probably us de Nicola raise
your hands I thought we're talking about
the American Brian Nicola but no it's us
this email comes from your homeland from
your friend Gavin you know gávea us and
he said I would love to request a
shout-out for my good friends Brian and
Nicola they have travelled all the way
from far north of England to complete
the compulsory Brit review of the former
colonies we have to check if you guys
are looking after yourselves well thank
you for checking a little look in yeah
anyway Brian is my best friend and the
one I owe an eternal gratitude for for
introducing me to HBO
however Brian and I worked together as
part of a very tiny team and he has
shown no remorse whatsoever for dropping
us in the [ __ ] by disappearing for
nearly three weeks to the other side of
the pond well you're a [ __ ] miserable
co-worker so leaving the rest of us to
really struggle and to dream of revenge
so you're in for it when you get home
that's all I got say yeah well
wanted to welcome you here so welcome to
both of you and ah yes welcome from all
the way from [ __ ] some other place
where in the north are you from
Newcastle Newcastle that's where John
Constantine was from Hellblazer [ __ ]
you read that comic book No
oh my god he's like the hero of your
[ __ ] hometown he's like the only good
thing that came out of Newcastle in the
comics that's what they know buddy you
went right to comic books I thought
Newcastle Brown Ale that's where my mind
went you went to beer yeah you went to
comics I went to booze oh we're so cut
cigarettes they sell those they're so
cuts and a brand or something yeah they
saw them all over the UK everything I
know about life I know for movies and
comic books yes welcome from Newcastle
that's only funny if you ever heard that
commercial oh yeah it's a very popular
commercial here it's really not that
funny though as you could tell a pity
laugh even the eighteen-year-old kid was
like I came to this it's making cough
drop jokes look halfway through the show
he's gonna ask his aunt why don't you
get me laid today I'm a man you heard
the fat guy a Joel and Erica or Joe and
Erica here that had some noise
[ __ ] noise Joel it's my boy
Joel says I sent you an email to let you
know my beautiful girlfriend Erica and I
would be coming to the show I mentioned
we were going to my mom and she asked if
she could come with us his mom there -
hi mom I met these cats in the elevator
before man on the way up seriously we
were in the elevator together did you
smoke out together yeah I was hanging
out with his mom was like you want to
get high lady and surprisingly she was
like Fakih hats how's that you're gonna
need it the shows not good mom
machi they're what we would love to come
with us because laughter is the best
medicine okay she is a breast cancer
survivor
whoa
I hope this isn't counters treatment
because I don't know how much we can
give you tonight like 10 cc's of
laughter it's about all we can manage
she's a very laid-back person so she'll
be okay with the [ __ ] jokes Joel writes
right on man cuz we got mothers I'm very
nervous all of a sudden yeah it's a real
family affair yeah man welcome please
give my two favorite women on the planet
a shout out in the voice of your choice
what we just did in our own voices Joel
so there you go yeah don't make us clown
it up yeah really Robert and Elizabeth
are you guys here everybody's right up
front Jesus the same table how ironic I
just found out my kick-ass girlfriend
Elizabeth bought us tickets for tomorrow
night's show I guess you wrote this
yesterday I'm guessing it's done [ __ ]
Jessica Fletcher man as Straight Outta
Cabot Cove I'm like Jethro Bodine I'm
doing some ciphering Billie's laughing
over here wasn't a 18 year old kid
that's for sure oh yes no I did it took
her for a while to give it a listen
regarding HBO but now she listens all
the time well I'm glad that you've
corrupted her thank you sir but listen
you guys since the beginning Kevin I
just want to say thank you for your
movies good and bad I don't remember I
am also a writer and director and was
pretty bummed about your retirement from
the director chair well it's not for a
while yeah I don't believe I don't
believe it watch the next 10 years
they're gonna be interesting I was
bummed too because he's the only
director who will give me work in movies
so when he stops making movies I stopped
acting in movies I'm more bummed than
you are sir gratulations on one year of
babbling cheers to ten more yeah like
will last ten years that'll happen thank
you so much for coming out tonight
appreciate it thanks for being here I
agree I think we'll ask this show will
last a thousand years
or the Fourth Reich no I think will last
ten years it's easy you're high well I
mean yeah that's
the point now you don't think what do
you think you like your foe for we start
fighting or I probably won't live ten
years more that's what I'm thinking
about good point with my liver you're
kidding me yeah yeah you might just work
with my liver my liver will be up here
on stage with you that'd be amazing
could it still do impressions sure give
me do a heart along we'd put those
googly eyes on top of it look at Geico
commercial yes put a Mike next to it and
[ __ ] and you're like ah is that what you
just steel me down to just the really
but I could do that like I'd pretend
you're obviously dead
it's just your liver with googly eyes on
it so I always turn you just for [ __ ]
the ones I could do with a ventriloquist
act
how about Derek is Derek here tonight
Derek Oh what I read when I read their
email you'll understand the somber tone
in his voice confirmation I'm gonna buy
Derek a drink I'm gonna start off the
email by saying that out loud
here's Derek's email after being
unemployed for over a year
oh my soon-to-be ex-wife told me she
wanted a divorce oh so I did what any
self-respecting man would do I packed up
all my belongings into my car and got
the [ __ ] out of there make a move make a
change man now I finally have a job and
the freedom that comes from knowing I'm
no longer married to crazy don't get me
wrong I'm sure I'll stick my dick in
crazy again but marriage no sir from two
guys who are still stuck in crazy we
salute you that's right got over the
wall congratulations you beat the guard
dogs and lo and the searchlights I'll be
at the show by myself because my friends
would rather spend $80 to see rancid I
told them if they want to hear someone
talk full [ __ ] you're usually more
than happy to oblige what I'm saying is
the singer for answered sounds [ __ ]
yes I think we get that Derek thank you
anyway listening to your show I started
from number one I've heard them all it
made me laugh during some pretty [ __ ]
dark time
for the laughs look forward to seeing
you live Derick well dari thanks for
coming man as I mentioned there's a
drink coming to you from me and I'm
assuming you are drinking right you are
- yeah that's what I'm talking about
first he was afraid he was petrified
thinking that he'd never live without
crazy by his side well done dude way to
[ __ ] get out and claim your life back
and [ __ ] now go find new crazy that's
right
emails from around the world James
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions our first
email is from Missoula Montana with me
the show it was when her father who was
Leland Palmer there are spoilers if
you've never seen if you've never seen
Twin Peaks
Oh get it get it it's [ __ ] like get
get it get weed and watch it all the way
through yeah because I watched it
straight I was like what [ __ ] 18 I
think when I was on the air something
like that I should rewatch it with weed
now that'd be amazing but anyway it's a
worth watching wonderful series
particularly season one but in any event
spoiler spoilers
her dad is possessed by a [ __ ] killer
spirit and he was the one that [ __ ]
killed the girl and then he winds up
killing her cousin right and when he
kills her that's what he said he's like
you're going back my dad he's smashed
her head into like a fireplace or
something like yeah it was really great
he lied she really wasn't going back to
Missoula Montana she was going into the
fireplace he was a murderer and a liar
and that I cannot abide yeah I'll take
murderer but I don't like lying
murderers yeah double bad no zebediah is
his name
of course it is he's from Missoula
Montana Ralph and Kevin I love the show
and would literally give my left nut to
see you guys live zebediah if you come
out I will pay your way out here if you
bring your left nut in a jar that comes
to our show I see I was just like just
show me your love nut
no I want it I'm putting it on the
mantle I came in late listening the show
being stuck in Missoula Montana yeah I
think they just got the Internet that's
why he's late I have not had an
opportunity to see you guys life live
Ralph I know this is a stretch but I
want to see if you have the skills to
pay the bills in the impersonation
department okay challenge challenge
really
can you pull off Edwyn as Vincent Vega
and David Lynch as Jules Winnfield from
Tarantino's Pulp Fiction the Royale with
cheese car scene it's pretty special man
it is but I took the liberty of printing
out that scene no guarantees save your
applause she's facing the challenge man
ladies and gentlemen ralph darling is
not going to do one impression front row
pull up the plastic tarp cuz Ralph's
gonna do two impressions one clear I'm
not gonna hit a melon up here I was
gonna bring a melon up and smash it
between each impression no just cuz you
spit a lot anyway okay you know what
they call a quarter pounder with cheese
in Paris they don't call it a quarter
pounder with cheese mom man they got the
metric system they wouldn't know what
the [ __ ] a quarter pounder is what do
they call it they call it a Royale with
cheese Royale with cheese that's right
what do they call it Big Mac a Big Macs
the big back but they call it Lubbock
back LA Big Mac
what do they call a whopper I don't know
I didn't go in the Burger King whoa
take that zebediah that's impressive you
did [ __ ] to this next email comes
from Canada a Todd C and Tito they've
got their own podcast up there called
the ymm podcast up in Canada they said
we've seen red state twice now once in
LA during the US tour and again in
Edmonton with the the Academy qualifying
run complete we want to try to give this
movie the credit deserve so they've
created the Facebook page red state for
Oscar and I think we've got a picture of
it up here this is the actual red state
for Oscar Facebook page so go there and
friend that because they're trying to
get as much attention for red state as
possible they said we feel they're at
least three Academy Award categories
that red state deserves a nod for Best
Actor Michael parks yes Best Supporting
Actor John Goodman Best Original
Screenplay Kevin Smith no no I pulled
myself out of it man I'm trying to get
the actors nods and won yeah I don't
that's what's important they've got
three categories here is just there's no
other actors mentioned on this list I'm
just oscar has an added these silent
category if they did I - [ __ ] swell
year yeah I know but uh yeah I think I
think you know some people go this
[ __ ] Kevin Smith Oscar no it's not me
it's that movie and it's particularly
those performances and I think there's a
really good chance that we could get
Michael parks or Goodman or Melissa Leo
Carey Bechet Carrie Boucher nods I mean
the performances of the movie are pretty
pretty damn stellar and all you got to
do is convince the acting branch of the
Academy
that's who votes on the actors so I
think that's easy once an actor sees
those performances they recognize
quality that's all I hear from actors
who've seen it like oh my god man I
could just
watch the actors act so there's a good
chance I think particularly Parks he's
mesmerizing you haven't seen the movie
yet it's on VOD right now you could
literally watch it in your house and
it's gonna be on screens can we talk
about that yeah sure
September 25th we're going back to
theaters and we yeah is the right here
in town we're gonna host the screening
at the new Beverly at the Quentin
theater down on on Beverly and that's
where we'll show the flick then after
the flick we're doing a QA and then
after the Q&A you and I are gonna do a
little mini Babylon right but that's
happening in that theater in Los Angeles
but then it's gonna be streamed from
that theater - I think it's like 50
other theaters across the country so
what they're what you guys would be
seeing at the new bed they'd be seeing
there and we're gonna try this out and
if this works it's kind of cool like the
theaters aren't like big multiplex
theaters some are in big cities some are
like off the beaten path so it's in
people's neighborhoods and stuff like
that but if this works on the 25th then
we could do red-state like once a month
with a different cast member like show
the movie stream the movie and then
stream the qat with like this time it's
John Goodman next time it's Melissa Leo
next time it's Ralph Garman but what I
like about that - other than like taking
a read stayed out repeatedly that means
we could take this [ __ ] show and
stream it into movie theaters as well
yeah and that's kind of neat like you
could literally go watch Hollywood
babble-on in a theater that's not out
here in Los Angeles so I don't know this
is a cool exciting thing for me anyway
September 25th if you want to check it
out in theaters with the QA and whatnot
here in town it'll be at the new Beverly
and everywhere else it'll just be a
theater as you go - Cooper's Dell dock
comic final list of the theaters and I
hope they have booze in these theaters
you're showing it out yeah well you're
the Babylon part at least you know
afterwards ya know it's gonna be dry and
we're [ __ ] and we're following that
movie which is [ __ ] up it's a nice
opening act
yeah murder and death and horribleness
and now here's Hollywood babble-on
this email comes from faith faith says
my name is faith she starts her email I
believe it and I'm 14 years old you
should not be listening to this show
yeah
really that's the first problem her
second line is I want to say red state
was great you should not be watching red
state faith where are your parents faith
where are they
secondly I listened to your podcast
non-stop it really makes my days better
you're 14 how much trouble could you
have so I decided to paint you too I
hope you liked them and she sent along
pictures of portraits of us that she
painted she's 14 years old and that's us
that's her work that's us
I she's got me my liver is gone I'm
jaundiced already my eyes are yellow and
Kevin has his mouth open waiting for
something to be stuck in it and I think
she has really captured the truce truce
essence of who we are faith that is so
bad those drugs are terrible she's 14
I'm kidding they're great I was touched
that's what I'm touched
I almost rolled the tear all right this
next email begins Ralph and Kevin member
of the Canadian garmi here my husband
and I are huge fans of the show I turned
him on to SModcast soon after it first
started right around 2007 when we got
married
coming up our anniversary a few weeks
I'd like to show him how much I truly
love him I don't want to get too mushy
but money is tight right now for those
of us in social work and I'm trying to
come up with creative ways to show my
man how incredible he is so here's my
request please wish him a happy
anniversary and tell him he lays the
best pipe around could you ask for
anything more than a wife and a public
announcement that you're a great lay
yeah especially using the word pipe yeah
you don't get that many women you know
they'll be like his penis is suitable
that's what my wife's a straight pipe
yeah I got a little hard when he read
that it'd be even more incredible if it
could be done as the McDonald's fry girl
he spends his days with high needs
autism brain injury kids and sometimes
he just needs a good laugh to deal with
the stress and the beatings
is he beating the children there this
letter went wrong man
your invitation always cracks him up
well that's disturbing on so many levels
you're the best pie player I've ever
made I love you when you lay pipe when
we're in the back by the dumpster when
I'm taking out the old buns from the
quarter pounders thanks for the pie
plane
[Applause]
you're going straight to [ __ ] hell
dude I don't want this from the guy that
made Dogma you're going to hell first
I didn't want to mention our names until
the end I thought I'd surprise him must
appreciate it Liz and my incredible
cocksman of a husband Tyler so Tyler and
Liz what I'm talking about this is from
Harry K and Virginia Beach big fan of
the show listen to all your podcast so I
made a short song for you guys from last
week it's my remix of the Al Pacino
margarita dance I don't remember the
margarita dance but apparently they were
I think Al Pacino said give someone a
margarita I think maybe last week and so
Harry has taken upon himself to turn it
into a dance mix glad we're enemies just
at the right time thank you yeah I know
that was awesome one more time man one
more time we queue that up again going
off well I think I think someone was in
the shoutouts early last week and we
bought her a margarita and then we found
out there was a pregnant woman in the
audience and I bought her a margarita
too and I think I think I did this
Pacino and I think that's where that
came from love it love it and lastly
this is from sue Wilson Ralph and keV my
young daughter told me a good Batman
joke the other day I thought if you
hadn't heard it you might enjoy it
I hadn't heard this maybe you haven't
either but here it is this kid was
walking down the street and found a
magic lamp
he rubbed the lamp and of course a genie
came out he granted the boy three wishes
for his first wish the boy wished he
could be like Batman so the genie killed
his parents
it was great that's the best part about
being Batman I guess you know it's been
a couple of weeks now we haven't had any
good death so I'm kind of bummed out
there's been no Tinseltown steps thank
god no it sucks no cuz when those things
happen they happen in threes and then we
always get nervous yeah it usually
happens to celebrities so I think we're
safe yeah it's true
those people credibility but I'm afraid
they're like the tensions building up
the pressures building up if someone
Goods gonna go cuz usually we have like
minor celebrities I think it's like a
crock pot lets the steam out you know
I'm about to fly to England for a week
tomorrow shut up alright sorry about
that but we do have a Hollywood helper
this week this is a celebrity goes out
of his way to do something nice for
someone who's not another celebrity
which is rare yeah well segment we call
the Hollywood helper
[Music]
thanks mister thanks mister we needed a
new jingle man you said that last week
what's wrong with it
hold on let me give him a track to lay
into it everyone shut up already mix
this in margarita man Hollywood help her
Hollywood help her there you go he could
send it back next week he's gonna send a
penny to jump it into the margarita mix
so it goes Hollywood help Uncle Rita's
but this is a sweet segment about nice
things happening for nice people and
that's a very sweet song that everything
has to be get your [ __ ] out filth and
disgusting this okay sometimes we can do
something nice this song sounds like the
Hollywood help her song now sounds like
a Catholic Mass like it's not
celebratory nobody wants to be there BAM
but more margaritas you just wanna
you're like let's honor him with
margaritas
this week's Hollywood helper is Josh
Duhamel with a guy from the transformer
movies I guess right does it do have
Duhamel do em all how do you say it
anybody home all Josh doesn't Mall
anyway that guy Josh from those movies
he was in Las Vegas to I guess the TV
series that's where he mr. Berg that's
how that's what we'll call him yes he is
married to Fergie The Black Eyed Peas
he helped out his hometown of Minot
North Dakota this week they have been
ravaged by a Kraken
no by floods oh they were forced upon
them from summer storms that just
flooded that area of the country and bad
things happened sounds like a Kraken
Kraken
so they've been they've been having some
hard times there in Minot and that's his
hometown so he hosted a concert there I
don't know how he landed her but he got
Fergie in the Black Eyed Peas to perform
as if that town hasn't suffered enough
now the Black Eyed Peas are in their
town anyway they threw a concert and it
raised a million dollars and all of the
proceeds are going to benefit the flood
victims they're in Minot North Dakota so
right on man well done well done
[Applause]
Margarita's not on that one you do like
my house my humps my humps more
margaritas you do a you're a frustrated
DJ aren't you sir
and I like James's job up there every
week we try to take a look at some
movies that have got mistakes in them
it's been a I have to be honest with you
I watched this is so [ __ ] I like this
segment before we get into it I watch
Scarface tonight they released it on
blu-ray
hmm whole movie I'm watching looking for
[ __ ] that [ __ ] be everything now I'm
seeing crane shots where like people
wait to move and I'm like that ain't
good enough and I'm looking for stuff
now because I love this segment it's so
bizarre
just to recap so far we took a look at
the kid who pointed to his penis in Back
to the Future 3 a little kid pointed out
his dick and going like this to the
camera yeah he's big Return of the Jedi
Harrison Ford grabbed Carrie Fisher's
boob yes the Harry Potter map the Rogers
map there was people [ __ ] on the map
we said that someone either
indiscriminate man or woman had
something drop out of their pants and
Teen Wolf we know that much Raiders of
the Lost Ark Belloc ate a fly Last
Samurai Tom Cruise's horse kick somebody
in the balls in the Wildcats a black
running back turned into Woody Harrelson
Planet of the Apes they ape sort of
half-heartedly threw a foam rock at
Charlton Heston didn't really commit
Ghostbusters has ron jeremy in it as an
extra you can see him and that moved all
right easy and last week was anaconda
where we saw waterfowl go up side go
backwards this week this is the most
request one we all receive and I've kind
of held off from doing it because
everyone knows it but I thought last
week we were talking about how George
Lucas was raping our collective
childhoods
and now he was making changes to the
Star Wars movies and this is a mistake
from the first Star Wars movie a new
hope I guess it's called now and it was
an actual mistake but it was it became
so famous that Lucas actually went in
back in and put a sound effect on to the
mistake to make it appear as if it was
meant to be in the film okay we've had a
ton of requests for this hundreds and so
tonight we're gonna take a look at it
this is the stormtroopers smashing his
head in Star Wars so we're gonna we're
gonna show you let me get my laser
pointer out here this is very helpful we
do the segment I'm gonna show it a
couple of times should we do the same
oh I'm sorry [ __ ] that should not be of
course James sorry about your Catholic
masses alright here it is the Star Wars
stormtrooper scene where the
stormtrooper hits his head on the
doorway as he comes through it'll play
it a couple times for you you want to
check out the stormtrooper on the right
even know why I'm looking I've seen this
movie so many times have a sound effect
then Lucas put one in because he can't
help himself there we go full taller
than the rest of the story is one more
time for good measure watch this stuff
right there Joel from Kansas City and
everyone else who suggested that that
[ __ ] that should not be for this week so
thank you so much new releases movies
and theaters as of today bucky larson
born to be a star as in theaters i'm not
gonna see this [ __ ] movie because of
the [ __ ] TV commercials one who is
that douchebag yelling at me in the TV
commercial bucky larson go see it i
hypnotized you bucky lots who the [ __ ]
is that guy i don't know let me see the
TV
sounds like Gilbert Gottfried though
worse he's more annoying that Gover gone
for really it's like Gilbert Godfrey and
Adam Carolla had a child this guy came
out stars Nick Swardson
Stephen Dorff Christina Ricci it's about
a guy whose parents are porn stars and
he decides that he's going to be a porn
star
but he's a nerd with a small [ __ ] so you
can see why that's funny and that's out
right now out right now you can walk
down the city walk right now and go see
it I bet that's okay all right
warrior opens today as well
this is the MMA movie and it's got Tom
Hardy anatomical obey
joel edgerton no one plays his brother
who's also an MMA fighter and by the end
of the film they're forced to fight each
other for the championship good how to
brothers who write on and they fight MMA
is the mixed martial law that's right
that said you Jitsu wrestling and rocks
yeah
no biting I don't know Nick Nolte plays
their father who's a former MMA coach
but he's also an alcoholic it's a lot of
stuff to handle here I'll teach you how
to fight kid but I want to drink first
there's a lot of those lines we ain't
brothers being partners and we ain't
friends
listen convict we're not partners we're
not friends okay I don't know what we're
doing here story jack [ __ ] you oh that's
my favorite
and Steven Soderbergh has a new movie
coming out today called contagion yeah
this is Steven Soderbergh version of a
disaster movie where a virus sweeps the
world basically and and kills Gwyneth
Paltrow which is all we can really ask
for right I think we'd all be willing to
sacrifice a few loved ones of Gwyneth
goes first Marion cottilard is also in
this film Matt again Mary and Colin it's
also in this film emails you wrap up in
there me go to Yaya
[Music]
Matt Damon man man bury me laurence
fishburne don't call me Larry and Judah
laws also in the village he doesn't like
it when you call him Larry you don't
like it we don't like Larry doesn't like
Larry and Jude Law that looks pretty
good I love you I'm a big fan of
outbreak I love disease movies they
don't make enough of them come I did you
ever see that movie I'll play yeah we
gave me the willies I don't like these
movies because you can't fight a disease
you can't see it it's microscopic yes
I'm sorry man if you can see it you can
kill it if you can't see it it's in your
bud we're up your nose you know it's
just all over you like this commercial
bad I like the posters are like don't
talk to anyone don't touch nothing yeah
like my mother growing up these the
outbreak you can blame it on monkey I
don't know where this one comes from
this time I think it's bird flu I saw a
piece of a trailer I read they said
something about bird flu [ __ ] birds
they go so you know there's a line in
the trailer where the guy goes can this
be weaponized and Larry Lawrence yeah he
says the birds have already weaponized
it so maybe it's like that bird movie
too man would I fight the birds you ever
see that picture what they called the
birds
oh no there was a recent one man like
weird kid made it on a shoestring budget
everybody the birds only thing angry
about that game is they still gave you
that stupid red bird that day it's a
good bird stop picking on the red bird
I've heard his [ __ ] it it doesn't carry
its own weight it's the Kevin Smith of
birds in that nightmare everything else
does something cool one guys zips
through wood one God blow [ __ ] up
they're all specialists except for the
[ __ ] red guy man
HBO headlines this week the rumors were
true as announced this week Eddie Murphy
will host the 84th Annual Academy Awards
Alessa fire that's good man I think
he'll be funny really
[ __ ] I come on the show taking place
in 1985 oh no I don't know Maddock
funnies funny at the end of the day I
think is he gonna wear a fat suit last
time he was funny if he did that would
be amazing he might do that man I I look
forward to it I think I mean come on
dude anything's better than [ __ ] last
year was terrible I was pretty rough I
was a [ __ ] train wreck
I felt so bad I wanted to go down and
try to push him out of the way and try
to do a better job you know they were
just really kind of lost but he'll be
Philby funny no coincidence Brett Ratner
is producing the show and he and Ben
Stiller and Eddie Murphy have a movie
coming out called Tower Heist in
November so it's a little self-serving
to have Eddie there but in Hollywood I
don't believe also this week Mel Gibson
while we're talking about movies he's
announced he's gonna make a movie about
the Jews he's gonna make it up this is a
make up to all the Jews
I thought you my name is gonna make it
up no he's not gonna make up the
stirring the Jews fought the Kraken this
is a true story about the Jews well as
true as the Bible can give you but it's
about Judah Maccabee who the hammer know
that's what Maccabees that means the
hammer yeah yeah yeah check your Old
Testament [ __ ] Judah Maccabee was the
hammer man a wrestler he's an MMA
fighter that was his name he was the
hammer they everyone looked up to him as
[ __ ] cuz he fought back and [ __ ] he did
he fought back he fought back against
the king he retook Jerusalem for the
Jews and he was the guy who stretched
one night worth of oil into eight nights
worth of oil which gave us Hanukkah
yeah and gamer that stop calling him the
hammer I'm telling you that's his
nickname another hammer Maccabee Mel
Gibson said he's going to direct and
possibly star as Judah here's the thing
about Mel he doesn't have the greatest
track record with the Jews
yeah some said he had an anti-semitic
take in the Passion of the Christ yeah
he sure blamed the Jews for all the
world wars when he was drunk and pulled
over in Malibu yes but this is his
chance to make good he's having Joe
Eszterhas write the screenplay that's
the man who gave us a basic instinct and
Flashdance and jagged edge and I think
showgirls do I think you guys showgirls
yeah yeah I don't really that's an
interesting choice to write it
the Jews are upset is that the title of
the movie no no they've just been
telling anyone who will listen they're
not happy with it I think because Joe
Esterhaus is writing it I think oh no
they don't like the fact Mel Gibson is
is going to be directing it one rabbi
told The Hollywood Reporter I [ __ ] you
not he said it's like having a white
supremacist play Martin Luther King jr.
I believe that so they're not it they're
not excited about the take on it but
look people said passion the Christ no
one would go and look at the money to be
financed is he gonna finance the movie
himself I wonder look it's gonna be him
and Warner Brothers they're talking
about going in halfsies that's a
Hollywood term yeah
I don't know I mean look if you're gonna
if you're doing a makeup fine make the
movie but don't cast yourself in that
role that's know yeah get like Gilbert
Godfried to play yeah oh we have some
oil but it's only one day so maybe eight
I don't know I've done not a good
measure
black Affleck
Jim Carrey is batshit crazy according to
this story we talked a couple weeks ago
he was seducing Emma Stone via YouTube
yes now he's pissing off his neighbors
in the Tony West Village of New York
City he was seen the other day
spray-painting graffiti on the side of
his own home on the wall there I think
we've got a picture of him actually
doing it this is someone took of him
it's him spray-painting on his own wall
said no one knows what the design means
you're lying what boy it's boring when
he was on Twitter he does this thing
booing he writes boring people used to
write it back and forth to him it looks
like a visual representation of boy huh
that's be my guess no one knows where
the FFC stands for either that he
thought father Christmas no I don't
believe that's it
freaking [ __ ] Kerry I'm thinking his
own house yeah and why are they mad the
neighbors think it might make the
neighborhood look not so nice when
people start spray-painting graffiti on
their own homes a lot of people in New
York move out of the inner city to get
to the nice neighborhood to get away
from the graffiti and there's Jim Carrey
talking out of his ass and
spray-painting on his own house it's
weird though 10 years ago people would
have been like oh he rocks they spent or
rode on his house but now like a few
movies that don't work out people are
just like [ __ ] nut bars writing on
his house yeah mr. Potter's painting
yeah Reese Witherspoon was hit by a car
this week whap them Oh mean what money
but me yeah when did this happen
Wednesday how do you have an alibi yeah
I was busy doing something no she was
jogging see exercise I'll [ __ ] kill
you people I've been saying that for
years
you had a good reason to stay home she
was jogging in Santa Monica on Wednesday
morning and an 84 year old woman went
through a intersection and clipped her
in the crosswalk
it's okay she was only going 20 miles an
hour that's not a joke she was going 20
miles an hour she really hit reese
witherspoon who's they say just suffered
minor injuries was transported to a
local hospital and she was released that
day she's fine because the car hit her
in the chin absorbed all the impact
she's got a big chair really a huge huge
a big Lantern jaw of a chin yeah Jay
Leno of Jay Leno of women is what she is
apparently the woman was cited for
failing to yield a pedestrian in a
crosswalk and for not finishing the job
apparently police were upset with her
for not taking out greasy Reese's sorry
ladies but Neil Diamond's off the market
I know he's gone I said the 70 year old
icon is engaged to his co manager KT
McNeal that means she'll be KT McNeal
Dimond when she marries him this is his
third wife he's 70 years old as I
mentioned sweet viagra those diamonds
they work so good he was married when he
was high school sweetheart in 63 and
then married to another woman for 26
years before they divorced and now he's
moving on to his third so hey McNeal man
the song she's gonna be hearing he's
like I'm coming in America today
right now on your booth Oh Charlie
Sheen's roast is gonna be taped on
Monday night will be aired of course on
the 19th the same night that two and a
Half Men is going to be airing this
didn't happen no there's still always
happened already filming it on Monday
night they just added some additional
names to the dais who will be making fun
of Charlie William Shatner will be
cracking wise at Charlie's expense give
us a taste of what that might sound like
you do so much crap and you [ __ ] bone
stars I'm jealous
hilarious private practice star Kate
Walsh will be up there what the [ __ ] I
saw her on The Tonight Show once she
wasn't very fun no I don't stand why
she's there Guns & Roses guitarist Slash
will be giving us his comedy stylings
Mike Tyson will be up there so we got
that yes oh so ridiculous with all your
craziness
I can't believe everybody throw people's
couple jabs before he leaves but the
reason I really brought this up is
because the pod father himself is going
to be there Jon Lovitz will be on the
diet Babli [ __ ] loved our of sorry
Night Live and and this joint the Jon
Lovitz podcast theater that's right it's
not here tonight is he Johnny you in the
crowd no
I'm home counting the money do you think
you should write him some jokes do some
Charlie jokes didn't Samir Charlie do
not take responsibility for whatever
happens up there other watches an
innocent bystander stopped you held it
got blue balls they're gonna air that
the same night as they doing ahead two
and a half man yeah
are you gonna watch either I will watch
the two in half man you almost out of
curiosity I've never watched a regular
episode of two an anything but I will
watch the new one just to see what's
what I've never seen mezame like you
I've never seen the other show but now I
might tune in to see I just want to hear
what they said they said he what die
gets hit by a train or something
apparently yeah in a meat explosion is
that a phrasing the train hits him so
hard he explodes into meat how many
years is he doing that show four five
alright so for five year okay so well
the shows in syndication yes yeah plenty
or plenty time let's figure 20 years
from now kids seeing that show you know
how people watch it like I Love Lucy now
the Brady Bunch is totally like breathe
they don't know the history they don't
[ __ ] another backstory at all you're
watching that show and then all the
sudden the main character like they're
like oh he got hit by a train anyway
look at this guy it's just gonna play so
[ __ ] strength will be odd yeah this
guy's got a lot of Twitter followers
though Lindsay Lohan it's in the news
this week James if you would lives alone
why don't you come to your senses why
indeed Lindsay Lohan asked to appear in
front of the judge on October the 19th
and explain why she has only done 45
hours of the 480 hours of community
service that she has to do 10% almost
not even though she's been out of jail
for some time now and they would like
her to complete that obligation to the
court I think I've seen a few stories
about her having enough time to party
all the time party all the time she's
been with Paris Hilton hanging out with
her she went to Kim Kardashian's wedding
she filmed a commercial at her house
while she was in jail
own a [ __ ] Kardashian's wedding
should be community service they should
take it at least an hour off of her time
for that she has only completed 45 hours
of service she has 360 hours of service
at the Women's Center to do Los Angeles
Women's Center which is for homeless and
abused women and she has to complete 120
hours of community service at the LA
County morgue
she'll be there soon enough so don't
worry about it she'll forget her time in
there I'm sure I believe aren't they
also making her spend the night in a
haunted [ __ ] house as well I think so
she wants to get her uncle's money she
has to survive one night in the haunted
house wesley snipes while we're talking
about celebrity criminals he's still
behind bars he is serving a three-year
sentence in federal prison they started
last December for tax evasion he's in
jail
oh yeah he's in the big house he's in
the gray bar hotel he's in the hoosegow
I guess you shouldn't always bet on
black inherently
I like that movie a lot really he has
tried to get a new trial with the US
Supreme Court and the 11th Circuit Court
of Appeals and they both said no sir
no they're just leaving him sit in jail
for tax evasion for three years so
apparently he can't get a new deal and
it looks like he's gonna do his whole
sentence Lindsay Lohan who broke real
laws she stole something she was at her
house partying on the roof Wesley Snipes
forgot to write a check that's all three
years in the in the federal pen Wow
I mean I guess they're really sending a
message like by taking a high-profile
person bill like look well even
prosecute people to pay your taxes
people yeah or just hide it in offshore
account more criminal crimes from
celebrities criminal crimes that makes
sense right even worse is I'm not even
paying attention I'm like you know that
went right past you let's talk criminal
crimes rough times are tough everywhere
especially when you're has-been
celebrity I think it's really more
difficult a Gumby was Gumby was found
guilty of a crime this week he tried to
rob a convenience store in San Diego
this week
Gumby walked into the into the 7-eleven
slapped his hands on the counter
demanded the money in the register and
some cigarettes from the guy behind the
counter without a weapon well the guy
refused thinking it was a joke
naturally as you would when Gumby comes
into your store he said I'm gonna get my
gun and Gumby tried to find his gun in
his pants
apparently the costume was too bulky
spilled his his own change out on the
floor got nervous and ran out of the
store
leaving 27 cents behind he actually made
a donation more than a crime I brought
in the actual video from the
surveillance camera
this is uh this is a little green slab
of clay coming in to be open into this
store he goes up to the counter I'm
serious I'm gonna slap my hands on a
very angry I'm angry Gumby alright fine
I'm gonna get my gun out I'm gonna get
my up I'm slipping I'm falling
I got change coming around who's gonna
[ __ ] get out of here I'm just gonna
leave
Gumby left with nothing he got zero
zilch
yeah day he had pokey waiting outside
for him to give him a get away but the
concert why why that outfit man I mean I
understand like why not just cut the
head off and wear that like why would
you wear the entire suit just like you
tied the tie the outfit around your face
mask rather than [ __ ] go in like give
me the money I'm guessing a discount
rack clearance sale that's what I'm
guessing it was the cheapest costume we
could find at the store I feel bad for
Gumby because the guy behind the counter
know who Gumby was and the cops showed
up and he described the perpetrator I
[ __ ] you not as a green spongebob
squarepants Oh Gumby no no wonder he's
resorting to a life of crime
no one even [ __ ] remembers who Gumby
is anymore
somewhere pogies is rolling a tear
imagine they don't remember us Gumby
blackheads are laughing we won [ __ ] the
cops say this is no joke they take this
very seriously they're currently and I
[ __ ] you not canvassing the neighborhood
looking for anyone who may recognize the
perpetrator
I recognize the perpetrator was a kid on
the weekends I'm thinking what I could
do send this poster around the
neighborhood this is the victory wanted
I know that dude
he was once a little green slab of clay
Gumby but you should see what that
[ __ ] can do today
Gumby he can walk into any book with his
pony pal pokey too if you need a friend
than a part of you Jess what Laurent
mean Gumby's a part of you
I think the lyric is if you've got a
heart than Gumby's a part of you oh that
makes more because he was that he was a
big hearted piece of clay yeah and you
had that in common if you were a good
person than you and Gumby had something
in common
of course Gumby could blow himself
because he was very flexible so he
didn't have that in common
all right the Kevin tried yeah I could
do it I did it I can't do it anymore
yeah without help see so Gumby is a part
of you his pony pokey of course was a
horse under foreign choice remember him
and while we're talking about horses
Sarah Jessica Parker was in the news my
wife's here tonight I can't be too mean
to Sarah Jessica Parker she likes her
she loves Sarah yeah the TV show not the
two movies we've talked about right
Sarah Jessica Parker's interview with
ABC News this week saying that she has
to leave America periodically because
she finds the lack of civility in
contemporary American society positively
painful in her words hmm she says some
people simply delight in tearing other
people down
I believe old horseface is right when
she says this and I back her 100% that's
why I say give her a sugar cube and give
her a brand new paddle or saddle she
hasn't had to deal with the real world
in a long time no she has even a
rarefied atmosphere incredibly rarefied
air even in [ __ ] New York she's still
not dealing with most of the [ __ ] that
most people though like when was the
last time she was in the equivalent of a
Ralph's you know what I'm saying and
somebody like fighting with somebody
over the last box of peanut butter Cap'n
Crunch
the vintage box could you like no it's
also a collector's item as well it
sounds like a personal painful
experience from your own history I was
just making it up she sends Broderick
out for the groceries right yeah really
yeah go stage actor go shop stage actor
he's like you're still here don't offer
him in a world where a boy can handle
that could take it in a world where
nobody recognizes Gumby I can't be
surprised that nobody catches affairs
we're showing our age Evan Rachel Wood
is in the news this week she celebrated
her birthday by going to Paris France to
party at the nightclubs there in the
city of lights that's quite a life isn't
it yeah she was out there in the dance
floor and one of her friends turned
around and elbowed her in the face suck
on that Evan Rachel Wood
she turned 24 this week with one less
tooth on her [ __ ] birthdays BAM like
a hockey fight just knock that tooth
right out of her head took an elbow and
[ __ ] like Gordie Howe Evan Rachel Wood
said it was still less painful than
dating Marilyn Manson oh sorry you know
the Marilyn Manson fan club was in the
crowd tonight sorry Jessica Simpson this
week reportedly was going to get breast
reduction so she could look better in
her wedding gown who's she marrying
former football player she's not
well-liked one more time Jessica was
gonna get the breast reduction as I
mentioned to look better in her wedding
gown till friends pointed out if she got
a breast reduction she wouldn't never
need to wear a wedding gown because
that's what she's got to offer her
fiance she tweeted I love my boobies
they're not going anywhere an America
exhales this is a great news story I
thought about getting a breast reduction
but now I'm not well we were all worried
she was gonna get it but it turns out we
could all relax now remain calm all as
well it looks like the [ __ ] Dukes of
Hazzard sequel can happen that's right
you guys remember sorry Night Live when
it was funny years ago years ago but
there was a sketch on that show with
Alec Baldwin who I think is the still
the record holder for most guest host
appearances on the show he did it with
Molly Shannon and Ana Gasteyer it was
when they did that NPR bit where they
did the the radio show good times good
times and he played a chef named Pete
sweaty and he came on for the holiday
season to show you his sweaty balls and
they were like popcorn balls and rum
balls knee of these delicious balls for
you to eat for those you don't remember
he's a little little piece of the sketch
from sorry Night Live this is the sweaty
balls
can I touch your boss go ahead but be
careful they're very delicate
Wow I can't wait to get my mouth around
the spa I like the way your balls snow
[Applause]
do whatever you want to them ladies my
balls are here for your pleasure well
Ben and Jerry's this week announced
their official Schweddy Balls ice-cream
it's their new flavor which combines
multiple balls fudge-covered rum balls
in vanilla ice cream flavored with a
hint of rum as a dedication to their
favorite sketch for sign outlives the
sweaty balls
do you want to be eating a bowl full of
sweaty balls at home while you're
watching television this is gonna be the
worst selling flavor of Ben and Jerry's
ever no yes ever since yeasty vagina
that did not sell well either that was
that was a flavor that did not did not
fly off the shelves this is a Bart
Simpson ice cream every kid is gonna go
to their mom like I want sweaty balls
you could be like why you and he's like
it's an ice cream you should direct the
commercial I just did yeah so look for
sweaty balls in a grocery store near you
I'm so eating that why are you so eager
to eat sweaty balls Tito Jackson is
going on tour to pay tribute to his late
brother that's Michael in case anybody
didn't know he is putting a show
together called a Jackson named Michael
remembering a legend as opposed to the
the family the half of the family that's
doing the tribute show in Cardiff Wales
this will be a touring show it's going
to be a Tito Jackson Rebbie Jackson
Michael's her sister yeah there's a rebe
believe it or not and Denise Williams
who is not a Jackson but she was on the
Footloose soundtrack I remember that
that's that's nice he Williams yeah they
were
they will sing Michael songs and then
tell stories about him it's singing and
spoken word
I'm selling tickets if anybody wants any
all right fair enough
kicks off in the UK in March in 2012 I
don't know why we put a large [ __ ] over
there in the UK they don't deserve it
toddlers and tiaras toddlers in tiaras
this shows on TLC getting a lot of heat
this week not for the recent episode
that showed a four-year-old girl with
fake tits in a Dolly Parton costume up
on stage for one of these little girl
pageants are you familiar with the
toddlers in tiaras yes this is when
Mother's abused their young daughters by
dressing them up like clowns and then
parading them in front of other equally
abusive mothers I remember the clip of
the little girl going I want the crash
yes that didn't upset people nearly as
much as the mother who dressed her
daughter up in this outfit this is the
pretty woman outfit for those of you who
saw the movie pretty woman you may
remember this is the costume Julia
Roberts character wore when she was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's what she's wearing
when she gets picked up the very first
scene Richard shows up in the sports car
and he pulls over and says oh there's a
[ __ ] yeah this is a three year old girl
named Paisley Paisley smothers defending
the decision saying she would never have
put that costume on a ten-year-old but
on a three year old it's funny all right
I mean I don't even know if I would have
recognized her if somebody didn't head
and said hey that's a pretty woman
that's how the introducer in the pageant
they go like now here's pretty women
from pretty woman Paisley and she she
goes out to the song donut and a pretty
woman song that she shakes her ass
and I'm only three
[Laughter]
everyone look at me to finish here's the
thing about these pageants let's just
cut to the chase and put poles on the
stage for the girls shall we because
that's where they're ending up after all
anyway Oh weird it's treating your child
like a prop is kind of that crossed it's
a piece yeah I mean but you know no
there's no good upside to that except
for those of us watching the show that's
right
all that being said she's [ __ ] hot in
that out come on let's face it I mean
she's got a hell of a body for
three-year-old you know I'm saying are
you with me Wilson Phillips is getting
back together again hey sit down sit
down new people are gonna go crazy they
are not only recording a new album but
they've got a new reality TV show called
the Wilson Phillips project it's going
to document their fight back into the
top of the music industry it's gonna be
on television for a long long time
carnie Wilson Wendy Wilson and China
Phillips are gonna be there on the show
it's gonna air on the TV Guide Network
yes it's not just for saying what's on
television anymore
programming TV Guide Network has
promised them one full season or until
Kearney eats the other two whatever
comes first so we'll have to wait and
see reality television news the
Kardashians in the news again this is an
interesting story I don't know if you
heard or not but they have their own
clothing line in Sears only the best for
the Kardashians washer and dryer and the
craftsman chainsaw you can get the
Kardashian Kollection with a K Thompkins
by cardi that's right
and Annie Leibowitz the legendary
photographer did all his Rolling Stone
covers for many years she was the one
shooting them for the advertising
campaign people couldn't help but notice
there was something up with the photos
when they took a look at them let's take
a look at one of the one of the pictures
for the advertising campaign the person
there's the three code Asian girls
together people said women isn't Chloe
like a giant hulking be a myth of a
woman and the other two or five -
they're photoshopping Chloe to make her
look more Sun more the size of Kim and
Kourtney what you're shrinking like her
yeah inches pounds penis they took it
all off her testicles they just they
changed her appearance completely look
at this other picture this is them and
in their in their underwear in there
there we go
that she's not even that she's not even
near those other girls when they shot
that picture they didn't shut her in
afterwards here's the real Kardashian's
let me see what they she's the Chewbacca
of the Kardashian family
she's hunched down there on boxes
she later ate that award geek news every
week we talk about geek there's one of
our favorite segments a shitload of geek
news to talk about this week so let's
hit it James rockin camping camping can
the big gig news this week shoes you're
right sir absolutely back into the
future two shoes for those of you know
Back to the Future to Michael J Fox goes
into the future it's 2015 I think he
goes to yes and he puts on these brand
new Nike shoes they've got in the future
that are self-lacing you have the Nike
mags they're called he goes cool cool
power lays there it is here's the shot
of there's him as sniffing the shoe or
something what's going on there but
Nikes finally made the real deal they're
making actual replicas of this shoe
1,500 of these are available starting
yesterday you got to go on eBay and bid
on them you can't buy him the first pair
went for $37,500 37 hey there's a new
auction every day up until September the
18th here's the actual shoes you'll be
bidding on these are the real deals
they're sitting on top of the device so
a pretty special they did with what's
his faces and Christopher Lloyd and Bill
hader's in it but they there's a cute
little moment where somebody goes are
they self-lacing or whatever and they
cut the two guys who were like not till
2015 yeah I thought that was neat but
that made gives me hope I think maybe in
three years or four years they'll
release the mag lock illusion I was
looking at the prices and they all did
the base the base bid seems to around
six seven thousand dollars for these
shoes I mean I like to see you didn't
mention the case I haven't seen the case
really yeah it comes in a plutonium case
oh and that's kind of like that he has
in the beginning Back to the Future
right first when I heard that I was like
oh my god that's worth it and I was like
I have lost perspective money a [ __ ]
metal box and sneakers I'm like 37 K of
course my wife's here I like to tell her
I'm gonna buy eight thousand dollar pair
of sneakers that would be there
entertaining but I think it's neat that
they made it but hopefully they'll
mainstream it but here's the thing that
all of the proceeds go to the Michael J
Fox foundation for Parkinson's research
so it is a worthy cause so you can't
really [ __ ] about them getting a lot of
money for these things and they light up
they don't actually lock but they do
like I do later yeah there's a battery
in them and it's good for a few hours
you charge it regenerate sounds a little
shaky to me but what do I know of this
oh you're all we're thinking it you all
were thinking it I have to go back and
take back that joke Gillian Anderson
confirms there'll be a third x-files
movie America said there were two
x-files movies the second one was really
tough did you see it yeah I did yeah
I'm a huge fan of that show over the
second the second flick I mean the first
flick was a little tough but it was in
the middle of the show
yeah but the other movie was just really
far from the mark I know there's a big
demand I think for another x-files movie
yeah I'm sadly I don't know I mean look
don't do it as a feature do it as like
you know TV movie then everyone will
[ __ ] tune in that seemed that would
be the do it as a podcast this was a sad
sad story a mentally disabled man was
robbed of his Superman collection this
this this made me feel better
that's not funny sorry eight-year-old
mentally deficient man who's got a
Superman collection it was stolen from
him his name is Mike Meyer and not the
Love Guru Mike Meyer he's 48 years old
he receives Social Security for his
mental disability he supplements his
income with part-time work at McDonald's
I tried to do it straight but it's true
he works at McDonald's I'm what they
might do for me it's a sad story here's
Mike now we have a picture of Mike up
here sitting on his Superman sheets aw
come on how does that not break your
heart you and I are one synapse away
from being that guy dude I'm one shave
away from being that guy look up of that
picture and I was like that's hauntingly
familiar fat guy in a room with Superman
paraphernalia that looks like me at home
thank you
apparently Mike used to work at Hardee's
and he knew it this story just gets
worse and worse he knew a guy there
named Gary he didn't know his last name
but they used to work together
he ran into Gary at a comic book store
okay and Gary asked if he could come
over and take a look at his collection
okay Gary saw the collection came back
the next night with his girlfriend and
the girlfriend said hey Mike why don't
you and I sit and watch some Superman
movies so the girl sits down with Mike
Gary goes into the back room and cleans
him out of all the Superman stuff oh
that's so [ __ ] yeah took just it's worth
about $5,000 that collection took about
1,800 Superman comic books he had them
from like 74 up to present-day
collectibles action figures a lunchbox a
radio a television took a bunch of stuff
so folks in Iowa are asking a st. Louis
area rather asking if you see anybody
selling Superman stuff too yeah I just
don't buy it or turn those [ __ ] and
yeah but that's that was that was set in
human pieces of [ __ ] Ralph like Lex
Luthor to this kid Superman that's right
yeah so I just feel bad now about all
that MacDonald stuff I did earlier
Star Wars The Complete Saga is coming
out on blu-ray what's it a couple weeks
no way yeah no no no don't cube my son
to cash in on that vivid pictures the
porn companies putting out Star Wars xxx
a porn parody not star [ __ ] but a
reasonable replica no if I all accounts
it's it's pretty well-made it's got
legendary porn star Tom Byron as obi-wan
Kenobi what more could you ask for
in this film apparently all the
stormtroopers are really stacked babes
so all of the the stormtrooper outfits
are molded with big tits in them oh I've
seen like girls stormtroopers of
comic-con yes but it's like that
I brought any little footage just this
is this is safer work head so Ross won't
be embarrassed with his aunt or anything
but this is a little scene from Star
Wars xxx the porn parody how did my
father die a young Jedi named Darth
Vader
was a pupil of mine until I cut his arms
and legs off and not been burning in a
river of lava
[Music]
I think I want to go home now
[Music]
I'm Luke Skywalker I'm here Saviour I'm
being rescued by a transvestite and then
they have sex no I don't know if the
brother and sister have sex that'd be
creepy I'll be weird right they Han Solo
in her have sex but I would actually
watch that man it seems like it'd be a
fun funny dirty time glad you think that
way yeah
porn parodies are all the rage now and
now we're going to the next level
someone has made a parody of a porn
parody trailer that makes any sense
there is no porn parody for The Dark
Knight Rises as of yet but given a title
like that you know someone's going to
get around to it
so someone on YouTube posted a parody of
what they think the porn parody trailer
is going to look like so it's a parody
of the characters that they think would
be in the porn version and they're
making all kinds of nasty [ __ ] remarks
to each other like Batman is but man and
Catwoman is scat woman and Commissioner
hard-on instead of Commissioner Gordon
and poison HIV oh I didn't I didn't
write it I'm just bringing it in okay
here's a little sequence of the parody
of the yet to be made porn parody of the
trailer for The Dark Knight Rises it's
loading oh it's loading that's what she
said
we need a screen over us we can stop
doing this you do banal he asked sir
pain oh yeah this is my favorite story
the week by far you people are lucky
because we're running short of time I
only have five clips to play for you I
wanted just a sit here and play the
entire album William Shatner's got a new
album coming out you may have heard his
legendary version of Rocket Man you've
ever heard that version that he did did
you bring a taste or no I I didn't but
he's got a new album called seeking
Major Tom which is cover versions of all
songs that have anything to do with
space good he had an out not too long
ago called husband was actually was
pretty critical acclaimed but this this
stuff is [ __ ] magical I brought you
in a bunch of clips because I just
couldn't decide which ones to play for
you here is William Shatner doing his
take on David Bowie's Space Oddity this
is Major Tom Brown
I'm stepping through the door and I'm
floating and most peculiar way
[Music]
and the stars look very different today
come on make you a little hard does he
not want to sing it all well he does a
little bit here's another clip remember
spirit in the sky going up to the spirit
in the sky because it's in the sky see
it's a theme part of the theme of the
counts yeah here we go going up there
the spirit of the sky that's where I'm
gonna go when I die
when I die and they lay me the rest go
that goes in the place that's the bed
yeah that's Phil he doesn't make it
sound like the best place how about she
blinded me with science yes she blinded
me with science
blinded me with science and failed me in
geometry remember Steve Miller space
cowboy cowboy I'm sure you know where
it's at yeah yeah
[Music]
but I saved the best for last this is a
double-disc set by the way this cell
phone it's like 30 tracks on this it
sounds like you recorded it in an hour
they just read lyrics out loud he breaks
with the theme at one point it gives us
his version of Queen's Bohemian Rhapsody
I predict those of you who are single
will be dancing to this as your first
dance at your wedding when you hear this
version this is William Shatner's
Bohemian Rhapsody
mama
just kill the man
put a gun against his head pulled my
trigger now he's dead life had just
begun but now I've gone and through it
all the way I'm gonna laughing all day
at this I'm still laughing if that
counts I think I could pull off an out
absolutely you could I keep telling you
we need to a musical version of Babylon
at some point we need to put some
numbers together Leah
nice in sky
I don't wanna choke the end of Hollywood
babble and thanks so much for coming out
tonight everybody ups to you everybody
thank you for being here garmi
represents on this Friday Babylon but
before we go we do have to ask that
musical question we asked at the show
every week just how big is Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] you're singing more than he just
was how big is lead me since [ __ ] until
we ask every week John McGuire in
Glasgow Scotland started this all off
and we appreciate it here is the first
of many Liam Neeson cocked facts Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it will be
partnered with Chaz Bono on this
season's Dancing with the Stars Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it's so big
there are our three dwarves operating it
from inside Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
sometimes he and Tom Hanks jump on it to
play chopsticks Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big a census taker once tried to
interview it and it ate his liver with
some fava beans and a nice Chianti Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big how big is it
and it just got hired to narrate the
Morgan Freeman's story that's delivery
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big how big is
it
it's the reason Morrissey is so
depressed I knew there had to be a
reason Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
Jennifer Connelly had to find her way
through it to rescue her brother from
jerath the Goblin King the hardcore
geeks are laughing at that one turn back
Sarah it's a giant [ __ ] Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big how big is his urethra
has a pit crew Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big how big is it now when it looks into
the abyss the abyss looks away Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big how big is it
it knows what the lyrics to Bohemian
Rhapsody mean I've always wondered that
I do not we're not let you go
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big how big is
it that when he has sex with a black
woman it's technically a hate crime
just technically not by intent Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big how big is it
it put a bounty on Boba Fett Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that when he
gets a boner in public it looks like
he's performing a caber toss your
Scottish listeners will love this the
guy wrote people in Scotland are
laughing I think the cavers like a big
telephone kind of thing that they throw
right yeah it's gonna be huge in
Scotland trust me Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big how big is it that the
international sign for choking is also
the same international sign for Liam
Neeson's getting a [ __ ] Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big how big he once passed a
kidney stone at a bowling alley and got
a strike Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
phil collins felt it coming in the air
tonight
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
sadly we have more Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big
acapulco cliff divers leap off it for
practice Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
Wow once a year the EPA releases a
report detailing the impact its
admissions have on the environment Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it walks
downstairs alone or in pairs and makes a
sling Katti sound this [ __ ] is so big
women need three tanks of gas just to
ask him was it good for you to drive
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it calls
dibs on the top bunk Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big it holds the only win over
Parker Louis thanks a minute oh my god
there's like [ __ ] one person in the
world laughing at that and it's the guy
who played for Elise Corinne emic
[ __ ] remembered would you watch that
show zone I wish it was me Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big how Bruce Willis will
actually take direction from it
and lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
when Liam Neeson here's Kevin and Ralf
shoutout theme by the time he gets his
[ __ ] out the show is over
that is Hollywood babble-on for this
week ladies and gentlemen thank you for
being here I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Ralph Garman babble the [ __ ] ah good
night everybody
thanks for coming out one more time for
Kevin Smith the Ralph Garman Hollywood
babble-on live at the John
pastor
[Music]